chief White House correspondent John
Roberts is standing by now on the North
Lawn he even junk bracket evening T o is
widely expected as Catherine mentioned
that Andrew McCabe was going to retire
sometime in March but the timing of
today's announcement appeared to catch
even the White House off-guard the White
House had nothing to say about the
resignation of the FBI deputy director
today other that insisting president
Trump had nothing to do with it we've
seen the numerous ports as all of you
have and any specifics I can tell you
none of this decision was made by that
of the White House but the president was
certainly shedding no tears about Andrew
McCabe's departure in December he
tweeted how can FBI deputy director
Andrew McCabe be given $700,000 for
wife's campaign by Clinton puppets
during investigation the timeline wasn't
exactly accurate but the president
didn't seem to care following up with
another tweet FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe is racing the clock to retire
with full benefits 90 days to go you say
that the White House was not involved in
the decision but clearly the president
seemed to be involved in a public
relations campaign against McCain oh
look the president stands by his
previous comments but in terms of the
situation today as I just said we've
seen the reports just as all of you have
we don't have any specific comments and
I would refer you to the FBI for any
specifics the McCabe announcement took
the spotlight off president Trump's
preparation for the State of the Union
address tomorrow the speech will break
down into five categories jobs in the
economy infrastructure immigration trade
and national security the president will
throw down the gauntlet to Democrats to
cut a deal to fix daca enhance border
security including a wall and end chain
migration and the diversity Visa Lottery
but hopefully the Democrats will join us
or mmm [ __ ] them will join us so we can
really do something great for daca and
for immigration on national security the
president will again stress the crucial
need to turn back North Korea's nuclear
program defeat Isis and rein in Iran's
destabilizing behavior today President
Trump hosted the UN National Security
Council for lunch
they also saw remnants of what the US
says was an Iranian missile fired into
Saudi Arabia a Yemeni Houthi rebels at
the president's side for lunch you an
ambassador nikki Haley who is sharply
critical of a Grammy segment last night
were celebrities including Hillary
Clinton read from the tell-all book fire
and fury one reason why he likes to eat
at McDonald's in a tweet Haley ripped
the program writing I have always loved
the Grammys but to have artists to read
the fire and fury book killed it don't
ruin great music with trash some of us
love music without the politics thrown
in it and after a night where many of
the artists wore white roses in support
of the me to movement Hillary Clinton
came under criticism from her former
campaign manager for shielding a mail
campaign aide accused of sexual
harassment
my recommendation to the senator was to
fire and I was overruled it was the
wrong call tomorrow night's State of the
Union address will be an opportunity for
the president to seize the attention of
the nation what remains to be seen
can he convert that into momentum for
his 2018 agenda or like last year's
address will the afterglow be derailed
by the latest shooter drop in the Russia
investigation
Brett John Roberts live in the North
Lawn John thank you